This episode of "Shots
of Awe" is brought you
by the Toyota Prius.
Let's lead the way.
So, I'm fascinated by the extent
to which our environment molds
and shapes us, how what is
without, becomes within.
And so I recently
discovered this term
called ontological designing,
which is essentially
this notion that everything we
design is designing us back.
We, we, from inside
out, we are designed
by that which we have designed.
So there's this circularity,
this meaning making circle,
this hermeneutic circle,
You know, we're
like the Ouroboros.
We're like the snake
eating its own tail.
We're like Escher's hands.
You know, the hand
that's drawing
that hand that is drawing it.
These feedback loops
are where mind emerges.
And it turns out that mind,
that really subjectivity, who
we are as life
beings in the world,
exists in that feedback loop,
emerges in that feedback loop.
We learn language but
then that language
molds our personalities.
And then our molded
personalities
use language to speak out.
And then that which we speak
and read in turn changes us.
And there's this circularity.
So Marshall McLuhan used to talk
about the role of technology
in this space, in this context.
So we build the tools but
then those tools build us.
We build these smartphones
and these smartphones change
how we think and they
change our behavior.
That's why they used to say
that the PC, the computer
was the LSD of the '90s
because the computer
revolution literalized
the dream of expanding
our minds through the
use of our feedback
with these tools
and these computers.
Stephen Johnson
takes it further.
He talks about architecture.
He says our thoughts
shape our spaces.
We design the world.
But those spaces
return the favor.
So we build these
cathedrals and then
those cathedrals build
cathedrals inside our minds
essentially.
We mirror the environment
that we create.
So what is our
responsibility then,
when we build the cities of
the 21st century, the city
planners, the urban
designers, how
do we make better systems
thinking, better feedback
loops, to kind of like upgrade
how we function in the world,
to upgrade mankind
and to understand
the city as an organism.
And as Geoffrey West says
from the Santa Fe Institute,
cities are like organisms.
Alleys are like capillaries.
And so understanding
these feedback loops,
observing these feedback loops,
upgrading these feedback loops,
allows us to raise the
stage in which we unfold.
And that's why ontological
designing is an important idea.